le froid n'ont cessé d'accompagner
la porte
ok les sentir très bien que
c est ce qu on
a compté la bataille aurait découvert le
contrat contre on avait commandé vu en
arrivant
d'ailleurs selon maria d'être fermé car
le groupe est
serré toi
ok
ok ok
enfin pas tant aimés puis stationner en
liga de
la saison et
que tu vois pas pour en dresser sur le
temps pas précis
cela commence comme ça après ce temps là
c'est pire pour notre patois
répondant
aux dividendes est passé
ainsi gate bridge est apte à fonctionner
car il adore a
pas de rejet
mais pas intégré
cette série comme ça c'est pas de
courant et c'est dommage la propagande
est très bien voilà pour moi ce sera
pour x
il va partir en laissant la partie
recommence
bizarrement on attend
a lancé boucher
ballack qui font la valeur a plongé il a
déplu aurait appris qu'il faut remonter
toi
c'est à dire voilà ceux
du riz et du souffle on a avancé que tu
restes à stature est vertical seul
d'ailleurs contre le dessus après se
lamenter sur le tank assez rapidement
même par mois d'avancé
place à travailler d'ici peu duo
français
ok
donc on attend qu'il
applique à rien car c'est dire que ça va
mal et s'est adressé directement c'est
pire
voilà
c'était bien de rien
du tout
mais bon tant pis si
la maçonnerie sur le temps plein
comme plongée verticale et obtient passe
au dessus
k
et
postale bien dessus de regard de
présenter quoi croire alors pas la face
aux questions
même si c'est pas trop bas ou 180
est pas notre pays vers le bas
ok elle a tenté gaz est bel
et bien
été refusé parce qu'on fait du tort à la
montagne la contacter